you've shot the entire season you're
here now we've only seen one episode so
I don't know who's dead here I uh
it's awkward I don't know someone here
is dead I know you're dead but I have no
idea who it is
and that begs the question how hard is
it to not give away a spoiler because
people must be begging you all the time
for spoilers you know and what do you do
what do you do when someone's begging
you please just give me something I mean
the great thing about spoilers is that
you can weaponize them sometimes yeah I
mean like it was written that Jon Snow
thing was impossible right but there was
this was close to when the show actually
aired so I didn't give anything away but
me and my girlfriend were having a bit
of an argument and the way that I ended
the argument was going
yeah well Jon Snow is still alive so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's terrible well grind Wendelin what
is your strategy for for spoilers people
begging you please they do beg but I've
learned to really utilize this situation
I always think it's best to make the
best out of any situation I was having
dinner with someone recently and they
were begging for a game of Thrones
spoiler and I said I can't I can't I
can't if you pay for dinner I can
why yep so I said are you ready and they
were on the edge of their seat they
really were they were primed there were
beads of sweat forming they were
slathering and I said in next season of
Game of Thrones there's cars so you can
just lie yeah that's what's wrong with
the Hornet izing lies yes
you